c'est une manne à une fortune colossale
voire indécente en ces temps de pandémie
father bio n tech et moderna les gens de
la pharmacie pour des profits record
plus de 65 mille dollars par minute soit
plus de 1000 dollars par seconde 93
points 5 millions de dollars par jour
avant impôts ces chiffres proviennent
d'estimation de people vaccine alliance
une coalition de 80 associations et ong
telles qu oxfam global justice now ces
chiffres sont bien entendu dopé par la
vente des vaccins contre le coc vide
pfizer a réalisé au troisième trimestre
2010 21 24,1 milliards de dollars de
gains représentant 130 % de croissance
par rapport à la même période en 2020 la
compagnie engrangera 36 milliards juste
pour le vaccin d'ici la fin de l'année
presqu'autant que le total de ses ventes
en 2020 qui était de 41,9 milliards
moderna un labo inconnu du grand public
qui n'avait jamais réalisé de profits
avant le qu'ovide tape sur un gain de 18
milliards de dollars avec son vaccin en
2021 alors que ces géants prospère qui
pulse vaccine alliance milite pour
l'accès de tous aux vaccins notamment
les populations des pays les moins
favorisés car non seulement ces chiffres
sont vertigineux mais il illustre le
fait que ces compagnies pharmaceutiques
choisissent de vente majoritairement aux
pays riches bio attaque a ainsi
distribué moins de 1 % de sa production
de vaccins aux pays à faibles revenus
tandis que modern a royalement fourni 0
2% ceci entraînant de cela environ 90%
des pays pauvres n'ont pas reçu de quoi
effectuer une couverture vaccinale
complète fighter bio n tech et moderna
se sont servis de leur monopole pour
donner la priorité aux contrats les plus
juteux avec les gouvernements les plus
riches laissant les pays les moins
favorisés sur le bord du chemin en outre
bio et eksi moderna refuse de transférer
la technologie des vaccins arn messagers
aux pays à faible revenu oubliant
peut-être ce qui est trop peu souligné
qu'ils ont bénéficié de huit milliards
de dollars dette publique à la recherche
ce mardi albert bourla le directeur
général de pfizer affirmé que sa
compagnie vendrait un milliard de doses
de son vaccin contre le coc vie 19 au
gouvernement américain à prix coûtant à
destination des pays à moyens et faibles
revenus mais cela avait déjà été fait
par ses concurrents depuis des mois les
compagnies johnson & johnson et
astrazeneca se sont en effet engagés à
vendre leurs vaccins à prix coûtant tant
que la pandémie était constatée ils
n'ont pas profité jusqu'ici de la manne
apportée par la pandémie astrazeneca
vient toutefois d'annoncer vouloir
désormais vendre un peu plus cher ses
vaccins dans certains pays puisque le
virus était considérée comme endémique
ce qui signifie qu'il sévira longtemps
johnson & johnson suivra mais ces deux
laboratoires promettent que leur marge
sur ses vaccins resteront modestes
concernant pfizer et moderna pour
couronner le tout ces deux compagnies
ont augmenté leurs tarifs cet été a
révélé le financial times passe en
pourfendeur de 15,50 euros à 19,50 euros
et pour celui de modern à 2 19 euros à
21 50 euros comme diraient les titres de
deux célèbres films prends l'oseille et
tire toi et regarde les hommes tomber